all right angel
yeah angel where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um originally
originally i'm from south dakota
the city uh actually uh rosebud south
dakota
and said that the seashore oh wow right
there yeah
up there
tell me about your your family growing
up you had mom and dad um my mother
my father was never around he actually
um got locked up when my mother was
pregnant with me because it was back in
the days of the lagoon squad and all
that you know and um my dad was
kidnapped
and
he
he stabbed a white man to get out of it
you know he got himself he was locked in
a basement and he got away from sad the
dude so they sent my dad to prison for
that
so my mom ended up marrying a mexican
guy and we went to mexico until i was um
five
and then we came back to indiana after
that my first language was spanish
mexican idea but i couldn't tell you
anything now
we were
yeah
um
and my mom was uh the murder capital of
the us at one point at one point yeah
yeah that was at the time when um i was
involved in the murder
uh one of them um
yeah my my boyfriend
um he was a he was like a prospect
between the cloven headers and diablos
right yeah
so was it okay
yeah you want to say yeah
the girl that he was with darling he was
married to um
she was messing around with his best
friend which ended up killing his mom
and daddy's mom's brains it's all crazy
all this is at one time
he the dude killed his mother and dad
because his father was molesting the
whole time and um he ate his mom's
brains
say that so he's be with him all the
time his name is frank street i never
forget
he was
i was involved with him for a moment too
you know
and
his best friend was having my boyfriend
my ex-boyfriend and um my boyfriend shot
another friend of his that was sleeping
with his wife this big triangle
and um
shot him in the head with a sawed off in
14 and cut him in half of the chainsaw
and then he called me up so he didn't
kill himself and i went out there with
my daughter
and i cleaned it up off the floor it
looked like two five gallon buckets of
chicken letters was dumped on the floor
and so hold on so he
told me that story in a sentence or two
um
again i don't know um
he uh
he killed his best friend you know shot
him shot him in the head
right here boho right there he said
can't even have a second barrel of acid
clean it i had to clean it up the brains
and this obviously you cleaned it up
with what
with mr clean
mr clean and bleach
but her body's heavy and big well the
body was in a barrel of acid on top of
his his he was a big guy like 10 pounds
and by his his torso was right here and
his legs were right here coming up his
shoes were still got nike shoes i don't
forget it on top of his shoes had um one
of the um
that plywood you know that that's
made with the compressed
you know would whatever on top of that
now on top of that was a lazy boy
recliner to push him down as he melted
in the acid
jesus
and by the time we left morning life he
was melted enough to where he closed the
lid on it and we'll take it up he left
it there in the front porch
and then we headed out for about a week
or so and then um
the police caught him in the cab i was i
was gone i went in with him and then i
seen him taken off in the cab and i had
to jump in there's helicopters following
me and everything but somehow got away
from him and i managed to get in the
backseat of the car with him
and the deputy sheriff that was driving
and um
the sheriff pulled up behind him and the
deputy sheriff put out his gun to show
him you know and it was like stopping
and jumping on his gun and said no keep
going
and they were fighting with their guns
and then i was just freaking out the
next you know i heard a bow and his head
just dropping blood went down both sides
of his neck
and he survived though he was in one of
them halo things for a while
that was like the most tragic thing so
back back to your childhood what was
your childhood um my childhood was like
my mom was always gone you know when
she's around she's with truckers and
[ __ ] and then
she'd be sleeping with guys in the same
bed with me you know they play with me
whether [ __ ] my mom and
share with us some fentanyl
so you were
there's some sexual abuse when you're a
kid
yeah
that's not what bothers me though
lose my mom bothers me
she's the only one i have i'm back
when did she pass away
um when did you lose your mom i i just
came out here to california when i lost
her
she just got her if i could fit no
patches back from the doctor
she she lost her leg because we were
changing the light bulb
and an apartment i got
and um
i said mom get on my hips because she
was like pipe it too
thank
you
she climbed up on my hip and the chair
went it was one of the outdoor chairs
you know the plastic ones the leg gave
out and went down and my knee landed on
her ankle and it just crushed her ankle
to powder
and so she was
she ended up losing her legs she was an
amputee and um
she hooked on the pain medication and
then
she was getting fentanyl patches in the
doctor and i would get them too i got
100 milligrams and she would get the 75
milligrams
and we used to come in strips and eat
them and uh
but i wasn't there every time before you
know i was there i could get a hospital
you know
i went there
how far did you go to school
i got my ged
i didn't get far
i was pregnant about i was 16
and my daughter how many kids do you
have i have two i have a daughter and i
have a son did you raise them
i am no have asked
grandparents you know
to go out and do it thank god my
daughter was there with me when when i
cleaned up the mess you know i was
almost 60 years in prison over that
and i almost lost my daughter
but my mother stood up you know you got
prison time over that too i almost did i
didn't oh you didn't yeah for my
testimony but i mean i didn't i didn't
snitch on him you know i didn't say
anything that they didn't already know i
just they already knew that i didn't
really that i cleaned it up but they
just wanted me to say that
i guess i don't know i mean they knew
everything away from the other guys that
went and told everything they i guess
they just um
i don't know they know i was 17 i was
young yelling
and they were threatening me with that
they taught me 60 years
in prison
and at first i wasn't going to say
nothing you know and then they were
telling me already that they knew that
oh we got their asset friend they knew
this person that person this person they
knew that i did this and that and snap
and i'm like
you know i was a kid you know i mean
i told him what i did
and drugs drugstore if you win
i'm sorry drugs started for you when oh
jokes started for me when i was right
about i was doing i was doing crank back
then
and chris i met
yeah but they caught it no it's crank
mechanism what was it technically how is
it different um it was powder
it wasn't crystals like it is now you
know it was a powder substance and um
i don't know my number the people you
just come out here in california to get
it and they come here like orange county
whatever they come get it you know um
we take it back home
back home it's real expensive
but um
i don't know i used to crank you know um
that was my first drink alcohol has
always been my dread of choice you know
extreme this is always
so would you consider yourself an
alcoholic or a drug
or both i'm both you both both yeah
i mean like i
i don't know what i'd give i mean
honestly i don't want to be sober
i don't
um
you know growing up was like my
grandparents had me a lot we still got
camping and [ __ ] when i was kid my
uncles other than you know they were
like brothers to me
um my mom was
she went there you know i'm getting
close to i had a baby
that's when i got close
were you using when you had your kids
yeah
um
i drank with both my kids
i craved weed with with my son craved it
and have it
um
me as well as an alcoholic that was
mostly thing i didn't get on opiates so
i married my husband
and since i married him he got me out
here and
on our wedding day he [ __ ] um i mean
on our honeymoon
he decides you know i'm a commodity he's
what he told me i was commodity
he started
opening my ass tell me go make his money
go my money [ __ ]
i stayed with him for seven years i'm
sorry i'm emotional damn it
seven years i stayed with him
because i married him i'm like
i gotta be loyal to my husband right
he's still out here
he's a piece of [ __ ] sorry but he is
um
i never thought about position
you don't do it back home if you don't
you know i mean
you're still
you never do it
new year's eve we're in a chair
out here
i was it's five mexicans coming in like
five mexicans they're entertaining right
and we're smoking crystal
smoking and i'm once i was touching my
leg and i'm like get off me dude in my
head like no let him do what he wants
so he left me in the tent with these
five guys
right he's up front smoking the pipe i
see a shadow
sorry
please shut it off
how did you end up homeless
my husband
um
we was in vegas at first and uh
we ended up in vegas we were never
homeless because you know i could ask
out there
it's just so money is easy to get out
there you know
i hear a pain handle you know i painted
on there too but it was easier to get
you know i thought you had just that
paint handle here you got like bump for
your money
um
i don't know he just
he promised me all this [ __ ] you know
and
they were you know my husband was a
self-serving perk he was he's all about
himself
i hate to say that but i hate that man i
do
but um anyway
um i've been out here 11 years
on the streets i just gotta
and then people are hanging around i
don't hang around with [ __ ] up people
you know
i hate really decent people i mean
anybody that knows me to tell you i'm
not i'm not a bad person i don't
i don't hear the people so i don't walk
the streets to prostitute now like that
you know my husband turned me out
he did you know and there's people from
the past that
i see every now and then for money you
know
there's one particular guy that i see
all the time you know
but it's good to me you know it's like
and i don't go on the streets i don't
you won't see me on the hot stove not
like that you know i paid handle for the
most part to give my money
and it sucks it's humiliating you know
but it is what it is you know you got to
survive so you're using
everything
and you're fitting them every day and
it's like
oh this is a straight every day all day
i gotta hustle to get it you know so
you're using fentanyl yeah crystal meth
the fentanyl and i use crystal with it
um i drink every day so to get that my
plus i got a cat and a dog you know they
take care of and their needs come first
you know so i got to make sure they got
their food and litter
everything they need you know i mean
then there's my needs next you know you
don't do crack though no good for you i
used to smoke crack you know i used to
smoke crack when i got with them
but when i remember i had the first came
out here that's how it was he would send
me on a trick for twenty dollars and um
you know would get the money then
buy him i'd buy a crack rock right and
he'd do most of it save me like a little
tiny oh he said hate that [ __ ]
such a beauty bastard
but no i hate crack i didn't i started
smoking when i got in this guy in
new york out with him he was smoking it
so i smoked it with him we smoked a lot
of crap
a lot it was seven nobody got we get one
free wednesday night twice a day
and a lot of crack so this lifestyle
living yeah content on the street yeah
doing drugs drinking prostitution all
this kind of stuff yeah it's just a
lifestyle i hear it's a lifestyle you
know like back home you don't do that
[ __ ] but uh hair is just the way it lies
you know
you do what you gotta do to survive you
give us
it's very depressing you know
but um what do you do you know what you
have to keep going yeah
that just makes you strong right
yeah my animals keep me going
what do you think led you into this
situation
my childhood yeah
i married him for all the wrong reasons
you know
my family never um
accepted me
because i'm a native american i wasn't
my mother was very prejudiced
everybody's gonna see me crying like
little [ __ ]
my family never accepted me
they never did
um
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i feel stupid
did you ever feel loved in your life
never
i never
i was just thinking about the way i'm
like
i've never
felt love
know what it is
i've loved
who never got left back
everybody just used me for a sentence
this way no i don't i don't think about
men or sex or anything i'm just like
what for you know
what are you afraid of now
died alone
i'm a dialogue
how old are you
47.
everybody had three mini strokes two
my papers shut down i'll make three
different times
it's scary
i got cirrhosis and everybody see and i
drink an alcoholic my liver hurts
what do you do just keep going you know
yeah
day by day
little my animals it's just keeps me
going
goddammit
sorry [ __ ] talk with your kids
do you ever talk with your kids
i haven't talked to my daughter
in a couple years
i miss her
there's a fine line between being a
mother and a best friend but my daughter
daughter were really close you know
i was telling you if you could change
one thing about your childhood what do
you think it would have been that may
have talked to you
about my childhood yeah
i don't know because i love my mother
you know
i still want to say mom
it's funny how we love these parents who
don't really treat us the way we should
right
maybe i want my dad around
maybe
i don't know but i heard my brothers and
my sister for my dad my half brothers
since then they said their life wasn't
that great either you know
you said dad was psycho
did you ever have any examples in your
childhood of any loving relationships
my grandparents your grandparents
yep
thank you
the best
my grandma actually
she had parkinson's disease um she laid
it in her
bed in the nursing home for months
didn't move
you know i mean we'll move her eyes her
hands nothing and then she
i got i was on facebook with my family
and uh
my niece
and she told me
my cousin actually called my niece
she told me that grandma was going
and
my grandma heard my voice and grandma
started moving her eyes and her mouth
you know she got excited to talk so i
told her that i was good i was safe
and you don't have to worry about me no
more i was away from my husband
you know which that part was true you
know
but she started moving around you know
just sharing my voice i know that pissed
my uncles up come on my uncles hate me
is this this lowest point of your life
right now
pretty much yeah
but um
you know i've had
i found relationships out here
myself stronger than my blood family you
know
and people are goddamn
like hey crying like this damn it and
then people that really care
you know
the other two friends out here that i
never thought i would have really
which is amazing
because they say all these people
overall scumbags you know that's not
true
we're not
just never had changed
[ __ ] dude i'm sorry i gotta hate crying
like this it's okay
one more question we're done what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
forgiveness
forgiveness
you carry that
hatred in your heart just wears down it
does
you gotta forgive them you gotta keep
loving
keep going on you do i know it's always
cheesy but it's true
yes
all right angel thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you sorry for hearing so much
you